[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
prosecutors give the okay to test for
dna on key items of evidence in the
so-called
fatal attraction killing the truth here
requires scientific testing the former
teacher out on parole
after 27 years behind bars for the
murder of her former lover's wife
and her attorney's quest to clear her
name when somebody's wrongfully
convicted
the real killer is always out there and
will never be prosecuted
a north carolina district attorney
announces no charges for two deputies in
the fatal shooting of andrew brown
willoughby guilty or an acquittal for a
former florida deputy accused of
planting drugs on unsuspecting motorists
and the jury is now seated in the trial
of an iowa man accused of murdering a
college student
and leaving her body in a cornfield plus
fireworks in the courtroom
as the trial of robert durst in the
murder of his best friend susan berman
[Applause]
law resumes crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the trial of millionaire real estate air
robert durst in the murder of his best
friend has resumed
after a 14-month pause
the new york real estate air is accused
of killing his best friend susan berman
in her los angeles home in december
2000. durst trial had three days of
openings and 10 witnesses take the stand
before colvin 19 postponed the trial on
march 12
2020. 12 people plus 11 alternates made
up the jury but one alternate was
removed
after looking at a news article both
sides got two hours to recap their
openings from last year
the defense maintains that durst didn't
kill berman and doesn't know who did
prosecutor john lewin says berman's
death had a direct link to the
disappearance of robert durst's first
wife
kathleen durst in 1982 and tied it to
the death
of his texas neighbor morris black in
2001
we believe that the evidence in this
case is going to show
that he is responsible for the
disappearance and the death
of his missing wife kathy mccormick
durst
we're going to show that robert durst
murdered
his close friend and confidante susan
berman
and we're going to show that he did that
with the motive
and because she was a witness
and by witness meaning that she assisted
him
in covering up the killing of his wife
almost 20 years earlier robert durst
killed dismembered
and dumped morris black's corpse his
body parts in trash bags
into galveston bay three killings
that we are going to prove
he's charged with the murder of susan
berman he is charged
with the special circumstance that that
was a witness killing
and in order to prove the witness
killing
we need to prove to you what she was a
witness to
which means we're going to be putting on
evidence that mr durst
killed kathy durst but before openings
even began
things got heated in the courtroom a
screaming match broke out on monday
afternoon
over the admissibility of testimony that
a witness claimed to see kathy durst
after she disappeared whether or not
the court believes it's relevant whether
or not court leaves
or not the theory and the information
and evidence that they have produced is
consistent with it
then the quark you may belong
thank you wait a minute hold on hold on
hold on please
look this isn't some late arrives theory
we've known from the beginning
that eddie lopez saw kathy durst on
february the 1st
they say they offered to
stipulate to that no they offered to
stipulate
to anything that was otherwise
admissible
this is a it was clearly a hearsay
statement so we couldn't stipulate that
so but that's not a lot
[Music]
down down
sit down
no you may not continue we are going to
be silent now
here with us today is civil rights
attorney jeff storms and terry austin
jeff get your popcorn and your candy and
allowance chair because it's going to be
a while
that's what ada or the prosecutor lewin
said about crossing durst
what did you make of the prosecution's
arguments in this little spat
well first i'll say popcorn was fitting
brian because that's kind of what got mr
durst into trouble was his cooperation
with that documentary
but with respect to the argument you
know what they're arguing over is
hearsay right out of court statements
intended to prove the truth of the
matter
here you know i don't know how much the
public understands but generally
lawyers aren't allowed to have hearsay
admitted but then there is a laundry
list of excuses which lawyers can throw
into the air
in hopes that that hearsay can be
admitted so that's what this argument
was over
here basically there really isn't a
clear theory as to why
this hearsay should be admitted it
sounds like they're attempting to use
the effect of the listener exception
which is pretty much a desperation move
in my opinion and it's highly unlikely
this is going to be admitted
but the least based on that argument
alone yeah now terry i get it's an
adversarial system but this is the first
time i've seen
a judge give a timeout in the middle of
the court it doesn't look like
this evidence is coming in because of
the back and forth but what did you make
of how the judge
handled the situation listen on the one
hand
this seems like a no-nonsense judge it
was like a time out it almost sounded as
though he was talking to his children
but on the other hand i think he allowed
for this to occur he jokes a lot he lets
the two attorneys talk to themselves
i think it got to a point where he had
to put his foot down
he's expecting a certain amount of
decorum and he had to admonish them
to bring it back to that so that there's
respect and professionalism
yeah of course we'll continue to see
that brawling between those two sides
almost like a boxing match i have to go
to their quarters
law and crime is covering that case with
live capital gavel coverage
make sure to check it out thank you both
let's turn to another trial
we're following on the law and crime
network a jury is now seated in the
trial
of christian vahena rivera he's accused
of murdering college student molly
tibbetts and janet levy tells us what
lawyers are asking the prospective
jurors
this trial was moved to scott county so
a fair and impartial jury
could be seated to hear the case against
christian bahina rivera
there have been eight women and seven
men selected to sit on the jury three of
them
are alternates bahina rivera is accused
of murdering mollie tibbetts back in
july of 2018.
prosecutors say bahina rivera confessed
to arguing with tibbetts and then
blacking out
during an 11-hour interrogation police
say bahina rivera led them to tibbetts's
body in a corn field in poweshe
county now nearly three years later
cameras are not allowed inside the event
center where prospective jurors are
being questioned
here in davenport iowa they've been
asked about whether they feel bahina
rivera being an undocumented immigrant
should impact how he's treated by the
criminal justice system
they've also been asked whether they
believe police are perfect or they make
mistakes
and bahana rivera's attorneys have asked
the pool whether they've ever heard
of what's called a false confession
opening statements will begin
early wednesday morning at the scott
county courthouse
in davenport iowa i'm angenette levy for
law and crime daily
thanks angenet and be sure to tune in to
law and crime network for capital gavel
coverage
of that trial still ahead on law and
crime daily why
prosecutors say there's no charges in
the shooting of a north carolina man
killed by law enforcement plus the
verdict is in
for the trial of a florida deputy
accused of planting drugs on
unsuspecting motorists
the decision after the break
[Music]
welcome back to north carolina sheriff
deputies will not be facing charges
in the fatal shooting of andrew brown jr
the local district attorney called
brown's death quote tragic
but justified the sheriff's office says
deputies were attempting to arrest
42 year old brown on felony drug charges
some of the body cam footage of the
shooting was made public for the first
time
the deputies can be seen in the back of
a truck then approaching brown's car
the car then starts to drive away and
the deputies fire the da's office says
the deputies shot and killed brown
after he struck them twice with his
vehicle
let's bring in civil rights attorney
jeff storms jeff this is in your
wheelhouse
what's your reaction to this video well
it's not the video itself as much as
how it was released for me brian this
was
a political and pr move by the
prosecutor's office
they showed us only small segments of
the video
which support the conclusion they want
the public to reach
about this shooting you know we can hear
from the lawyers
for you know his family mr brown's
family
who are going to tell us we need to see
the entire videos
because the videos we can see it
certainly doesn't look like mr brown
intended to run over an officer despite
having the opportunity to do so
so i think we need to take the release
of this video for what it is
a release intended to support the
conclusion of the prosecution's
declination of charges and as we said
earlier in north carolina the way it
works for that video to be released
it has to be court ordered perhaps we'll
see that in the coming future
thanks jeff now to florida where a jury
has given a mixed verdict for a former
deputy charged with planting drugs on
unsuspecting motorists
count one guilty of racketeering as
charged
count seven guilty of official
misconduct related to teresa odom as
charged count nine guilty of official
misconduct
related to joshua emanuel as charged
count 10 guilty of official misconduct
related to stephen banne
as charged out of 67 charges a jury of
six
found zachary wester guilty of 19 of
them 12 victims took the stand during
the trial
prosecutors say wester took advantage of
them and planted drugs in their car
a jury of six determined that was only
the case for three of the victims
teresa odom joshua emanuel and stephen
vann
wester was found guilty of three counts
of official misconduct
perjury fabricating evidence and
possession of drug paraphernalia he was
also found guilty of four counts of
possession
of a controlled substance two counts of
false imprisonment and one count of
racketeering
zachary wester took the stand in his own
defense and he said he's innocent
you did not plan any evidence that never
crossed my mind
no this is these were legitimate
stops searches and you found
illegal narcotics yes sir after the
verdict was read the former deputy was
cuffed and sent to jail
sentencing will be at a later date
let's bring in co-host terry austin
about the verdict terry
mix verdict guilty on only three of the
12 witnesses that testified
can you make heads or tales of this for
us you know i think it's always good
when you get a mixed
verdict because the evidence is really
showing the jurors
something in connection with three of
the 12. i mean they found the
racketeering count
but for the three i think it made sense
for instance
teresa odom of course the video was
clear
so they saw that they saw the planting
of the evidence
for joshua emmanuel because the fdla
said in their report that western did
not activate his body cam
until after discovering the evidence i
think the jury saw that as being
culpable and the same thing happened
with steve van the fdla said
that wester only turned the body cam
on after he began the search so they did
not like that the other
individuals it was a little touch and go
the camera was
on but you couldn't see and so i think
for the rest of them
they said no we can't find a go a guilty
bird
sounds like the jury really stuck to the
guidelines of guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt where there was reasonable doubt
the others
they found an acquittal when there was
uh guilty on those counts they went with
guilty
thanks terry coming up on law and crime
daily a deadly affair
did a school teacher shoot her former
lover's wife over a fatal attraction
or was she framed we speak to defense
attorneys for carolyn warmus next
[Music]
it was dubbed the fatal attraction
killing but a woman convicted of
murdering her lover's wife
says she was wrongfully convicted now
out on parole
carolyn warmus's legal team is trying to
clear her name
where's your wife
[Music]
and you're here with a strange girl
being a naughty boy i don't think having
dinner with anybody is a crime
it was two years after the 1987 hit
starring glenn close and michael douglas
carolyn warmus was just 23 years old and
began an affair with a 40-year-old paul
solomon
both were elementary school teachers in
scarsdale new york that affair turned
deadly
i guess you thought you'd get away with
it well
you can't betty gene solomon was shot
nine times in the back and legs
on january 15 1989 and prosecutors say
similarities to what happened in the
solomon murder
end in the movie are uncanny
investigators look to her husband paul
who was known to have multiple affairs
but he seemed to have an alibi warmus
reported began to talk to solomon
after he left her for a new woman and
apparently bought a gun in days before
the murder
she was later charged with second-degree
murder and weapons possession
prosecutors say warmer shot solomon then
met up with paul for drinks at a hotel
bar and had sex with him in his car
her defense says she was framed what he
did in this case
was he copied scenes out of the movie
to appeal to the jury about certain acts
which when you look at it in retrospect
it was all a frame-up
it was all a frame-up and uh it's a
shame
o'hara himself was exonerated of a
felony conviction 20 years later
he's one of a number of lawyers now
representing warmus some of the red
flags that have
our attention is that the spouse of the
victim
uh testified under immunity you know he
was actually an alternative suspect and
yet he was
you know so how many people if your
spouse is murdered and you're a witness
in that trial you have to have immunity
uh another person
uh a private investigator also who took
the stand against carolyn
he also was given immunity he claimed to
have sold you know
the gun to her warmest first trial ended
in a hung jury but two years later
she was tried again this time convicted
the new piece of evidence was a glove
later found by the victim's husband
but the difference between the first
trial which ended in a mistrial
that was eight to four and the second
trial where she was convicted is that
there was a glove that was admitted
into evidence that glove is found three
years
after the first trial by the husband you
know who
again is an alternative suspect he was
offered a hundred thousand dollars
for a movie if she if she was found
guilty
uh this private investigator who alleges
he sold carolyn the gun
he himself has now been arrested and
convicted of witness tampering in the
case that recently happened
jeff doskovic was prosecuted by the same
district attorney's office when he was
17
and convicted dna testing later
exonerated him
described says the same medical examiner
in his case skewed his testimony in
favor of the prosecution
in warmus's case it has the presence of
dr rowe who's a
medical examiner who actually altered
evidence in my case
dr rowe initially estimated the time of
death as being between 2 and 6 p.m
and upon learning that carolyn was in a
restaurant with the
with the husband of the victim he
suddenly changed his time of death
to between six to eight which had the
impact of
canceling out her alibi
when we come back more on those key
pieces of evidence
why the defense is requesting new dna
testing and the prosecutor's response on
the even of appellant oral arguments
that may shock you
welcome back we're continuing our report
into the conviction of carolyn warmus
for the murder of her former lover's
wife
she spent 27 years in prison but key
pieces of evidence will get new dna
testing
after her successful appeal one thing
that you have to remember is that
from the moment that carolyn was
arrested
until today she has always maintained
her
innocence attorneys for a formal school
teacher found guilty of so-called
fatal attraction killing say dna testing
could clear her name
if she admitted to the crime she may
have gotten out
a lot sooner than she did she did 27
years and she steadfastly
maintained her innocence throughout this
whole
ordeal and we're hoping that this
dna testing will finally exonerate her
a judge last year denied the defense's
motion for new testing
but they appealed and just before oral
arguments west chester district attorney
mimi roja
gave the green light for dna testing on
a tote bag semen
and a glove so they can actually test
for that doesn't have to be blood make a
test for it now
because when you're in a glove for a
long period of time i'll guarantee you
whoever had that glove on has where dna
that's the first thing but
importantly remember there's other
suspects here supposedly
and no one's denigrating anybody
supposedly she was having a relationship
the
uh the decedent with other people and
the husband was having a relationship
she has semen in the vaginal ball that
theme
has never been tested we don't know
whether somebody came on the scene we
don't know whether was a a lover
a boyfriend we don't know whether
somebody was paid to come on the scene
we simply don't know why not test all of
the evidence to get a whole picture
crime scene photos show the glove next
to the body but it wasn't collected
before warmus's second trial years later
the victim's husband paul solomon
found a black cashmere glove in a closet
and turned it over to the prosecution
dna experts said in 1992 that it had an
insufficient amount of blood to be
tested
the prosecution you know their position
at the trial was that that glove was
worn by the perpetrator
so i'm really really i'm really hoping
that you know if and when that
glove excludes our client which i'm
really confident it is
that we're not going to see anything
troubling that we're not going to see
any theory shifting
that instead the prosecution will just
accept what the science says
and therefore consent to the exoneration
of our client
two out of three of us have been
wrongfully convicted i was a convicted
felon for 20 years until i got my
conviction overturned
warmus is out on parole after nearly
three decades behind bars
but her attorneys say it's important to
set the record straight nobody
ever got wrongfully convicted in a
courtroom by accident
let's bring in jeff and terry one last
time jeff fair to say the major
difference between the two trials
is this glove that was found in one of
the more sketchier ways by a former
suspect picking it up
if there's no dna from warmest on that
glove how does it affect the appeal
well every jury is certainly different
but
you know we can look at this and say it
was a hung jury the first time
and the critical new piece of evidence
was the glove and so it's reasonable to
conclude that that
had a strong impact uh on the second
jury
uh with respect to the appeal of you
know if i understood her attorney
correctly
you know if if her dna is not on that
glove given that she's served her time
it could very well be the end of the
proceeding and maybe they
no longer move forward and she's
exonerated but i think
you know there are a lot of questions in
that regard with respect to family
issues and things like that
and part of the reason why we're getting
the testing now is this is a new
district attorney in the office
as opposed to the former one who uh was
trying to stop the testing so maybe
the information changes everything terry
after all these years do you think the
movies the media and the prosecution
could have gotten all wrong well they
could have gotten it all wrong i mean
she was in jail for 27 years that's a
long time and the entire time
she has said that she was innocent and
so i think the fact that the
westchester d.a mimi roca the fact that
she is now consenting she said it was
late notice but she's consenting i think
that's the right thing to do
sound smart jeff terry thank you and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you